foreign
[Music]
Josh Wells president of film independent
welcome to a very special edition of
film independent presents
um before we get started I want to thank
some of our supporters uh the hfpa and
vision media for making film independent
presents possible as our year-round
program and also a huge thanks to
Netflix for making today possible
um it is my enormous pleasure to welcome
to film independent presents the two
leads of Heart Stopper Joe Locke and kit
Connor Joe and kit thank you so much for
being here today thank you thank you for
having us it's a pleasure I understand
you're both busy in production and and
we'll get to that in a minute but I just
want to kick things off by saying and
I'm sure you have heard this a million
times but your the show season one when
it came out registered with people here
in the U.S so immediately and so
profoundly like it was the show that all
at once people in my life like all
different kinds of people from my 15
year old daughter to my co-workers to
friends who like all different kinds of
movies were like have you seen Heart
Stopper it was like the show that
everybody wanted to watch all at once
and
um
it just had such
I mean I think it's because the show is
so well made you guys are fantastic in
it the whole cast is great but it was
also the moment that it landed where I
just think it affected people
emotionally in a very particular way at
that moment
um I I hope you've heard this because I
think it's I know my experience is not
unique in that but it really it really
registered with people at a time when
they needed this kind of show so thank
you for that
um but I'd love to go back to the
beginning and ask both of you how you
um how you came to be in the show
um kit maybe starting with you how did
how did you learn about the show how did
you what was the audition process like
uh well it was a a pretty normal
audition process for me certainly at the
beginning in the sense that I got you
know an email from my agent uh
telling me that there was this this
project happening and and an opening for
a self tape uh and you know there was a
pretty basic sort of synopsis of it
along with the link to the webcomic for
Heart Stopper and I immediately read
through probably the first volumes worth
of Alice's
um novels and was just like this is
something that's really um you know
really special and really something I'd
love to be a part of and
um
you know there was a beautiful scene
that was that was paired with it to to
try uh and I really actually enjoyed you
know the audition process and sending in
that self tape by original audition for
for Joe's character Charlie
and um yeah it was a really kind of
really actually quite you know fun
audition process going through I had a
zoom meeting chemistry read with Joe
which was very weird having a chemistry
on Zoom
um you know our chemistry must have been
very good that they could see it over
soon but um yeah and then we finally had
a our kind of final meeting as a as a
main ensemble cast and it was great
overall it was a really actually very
enjoyable casting process which isn't
always the case
Joe how about for you my understanding
is this is your first filmed role yeah
yeah how did you learn about the the
project and have the opportunity to
audition for it
um well they did an open call for hot
stuffer which is where people who don't
have agents or representation or haven't
worked in the industry before can
audition to I think one of the main
things they wanted to do with heart
stuff always create very like authentic
casting and very true to the comics and
a family friend saw the open customers
like you need to go for this you
literally look exactly like the
character and I'd always
been interested in acting and it's
something that was like it was one of my
big passions but never thought that I
would ever be able to break into the
industry because
from a tiny island in the middle of
nowhere in the UK and
I'd seen so many of my incredibly
talented friends go off to drama school
in London and sort of have to come back
four years later because London's so
expensive to live in and they haven't
been in the right place in the right
time and
I never thought that I'd be able to do
that and so when heart supper came along
it was very amazing but I mean I did a
self tape it was the first ever
something I did and it was like my phone
on like 10 books in my room and it was
very very funny back and I probably
would look back and watch that and like
cringe out of my body because I think
that the way I act now is very different
to then but then we did
three or four Zoom chemistry reads with
kit
um and then yeah and then we did an
in-person one and yeah that was the rest
is history
so I'm curious before once you were both
cast
um
before shooting started did you have a
rehearsal period did you have time where
you got to hang out and just spend time
together
um not that you necessarily need that
but the chemistry between the two of you
just the the on-screen relationship is
so powerful and compelling and I'm just
curious like you know but how much time
did you actually spend together before
you were actually in front of camera
yeah I mean I think that we had uh it
must have been about two week period
that we had in rehearsals which was I
found invaluable I thought they were
super super helpful to
firstly for that chemistry aspect but
actually more importantly to understand
our characters a little bit more to kind
of get into the brains of that and um
yeah kind of just understand not only
how we would work as a cast but also how
we would work with
um Eros our wonderful director and Alice
alright uh and you know just the whole
kind of team in general
um but I think I would actually say that
we were quite lucky in the sense that
Heart Stopper
very much follows the blossoming
relationship that we you see it right at
the very beginning
uh when they they don't really know each
other uh and we were able to as we shot
it in a pretty much chronological order
um give or take uh it was it was pretty
chronological we were able to really
kind of develop our relationship while
we were shooting
um and just get closer and closer as our
characters got closer which was really
really very convenient for our on-screen
uh on screen chemistry
uh yeah it was great
yeah I mean and also I think one of the
only benefits of filming during covert
was that production didn't really want
us to mix with people outside of
the production and so we and
all our weekends as a cast together as
well as all our days on set so we sort
of bonded really quickly but I'm yeah
those two weeks rehearsal were
especially from for me and some of the
other casts you haven't been on on a set
before to just have like time to sort of
ease into it rather than
start straight away was really great and
also having Old Pros like kit was very
helpful
you know one of the most striking things
about the show to me is it to me it
feels authentic to your ages like the
voice of the show The sensibility of the
show a lot of times if I'm watching you
know you can watch a movie or a show
about
younger characters where it just feels
like you can tell it was like some 50
year old guy wrote the script and it's
it's like this is what life is like for
young people as seen through the the
mentality of somebody much older and
with this show I don't know it just felt
like
I mean this is a testament I think to
Alice's writing but also to the
performance of the whole cast that it
really feels authentic and lived in and
genuine and I'm curious could you talk a
little bit about that and also sort of
how you worked with Alice on the the
moving this from the graphic novel to
you know to the from the comics to the
screen
I mean I think most of the kudos for
that goes to Alice and her amazing
Skillet playing words on the page and I
think it was so great about having a
graphic novel as your Source material is
that you have like
so you have shots already and our
director would very often have the
script on one side of his iPad and the
corresponding comic page on the other
side and more often not lots of the
shots or exact replicas of the panels in
the comic and I mean it's great as an
actor to have a visual representation of
what you're trying to do
um
but I I think Alice is just
a genius and that's that's yeah
um I I also the other thing that struck
me when I first watched it was
and this just reflects on me but as I
was watching it you know the first
couple episodes I was like immediately
captivated one over and then I'm
watching more and I'm like oh no it's
like things are about to get very dark
this is going to take a turn there's
going to be like
horrible violence or abuse or something
you know and it never happens I mean
there is serious conflict and there's
there's serious issues here but there's
a sense of joy and lightness to the
entire thing that is really beautiful
and unexpected and it it really it felt
it did not feel phony it felt it felt
earned and real but very unusual and I
was curious is that something that you
were aware of as you were making it is
something that you all talked about
I think that it's something that is
obviously a very big element of Heart
Stopper and I think in many ways it's
kind of a selling point and and
something that
um separates it from other stories
especially queer stories because uh
queer media is so highly saturated with
sort of
um you know negative dark
um heavy stories uh and it's kind of
very very refreshing to have a story
that is just positive and looks at the
positives of you know the bright sides
of life
um and I think that you know there'll be
certain things that I wasn't really
aware of in in shooting but
you know a lot of the reactions to for
example one of the most iconic moments
in the in the comics and in the in the
show itself is Nick and Charlie's first
kiss
um and you do find that I found that a
lot of you know people who I knew who
are reacting to that
um were almost shocked that
right before they sort of leaned in like
right before they you know their their
lips touched someone didn't burst in the
door and stop them
um because that's I think become quite a
common Trope especially in queer media
that they kind of you know that
two men aren't even allowed to kind of
aren't even allowed to kiss especially
not the first time they try to
um and that kind of is one of the first
times where you realize okay this this
is just gonna let this relationship
play you know
um it isn't gonna you know it's not that
we don't have conflict in the show and
it's not that we don't have
um hurdles and obstacles for the um for
the characters to kind of you know work
around but it it does also embrace the
fact that it's too
teenagers in love and you know they are
figuring everything out and and it's
very beautiful in that way I think um
that it just kind of lets the the way
things naturally want to happen happen
uh which I think is lovely
yeah absolutely
sorry go ahead yeah I was just gonna say
guess just put a perfectly I don't
actually think I've got anything to add
it's just
I mean related to that I was also
thinking about the way the character
um Elle played by Yasmine Finney was
introduced like it's almost not
commented on it's like this is a
transgendered girl it's just sort of
introduced naturally without commentary
and
was just handled beautifully in the show
in a way that you really don't I mean
it's off usually made much more of a
point about it there's some right more
dramatic or traumatic storyline
associated with it and the way she she's
introduced was really
um unexpected and beautiful
yeah
and yeah I think it's as it as it should
be I think it's it's uh you know uh I
think
hell's story is a beautiful story
um and I think that uh trans stories
always you know need to be told
um but I think that it's yeah I think
the way that that Alice wrote
L story and a story between Taiwan owl
is is beautiful and
yeah nuanced
so Joe I would love to hear you talk a
little bit about your experience so this
is like your first you'd obviously acted
before but uh but this was your first
on-camera and first professional role
what was that it sort of just talk us
through a little bit about sort of how
you got into that and what you know what
what your experience was starting out in
that yeah I mean I think
knowing absolutely nothing about
this world helped because it meant that
I wasn't
worrying about anything because I didn't
have any idea what to worry about
um and also it was it was nice
quite a few of the main cast it was off
first on-screen roles and so we had
a nice like Bond because of that and we
could like oh it's fine I hope you also
just know what he's doing so it's fine
so I'm not the only one and I think I I
knew I personally can see
the scenes that we filmed at the start
of the shoot versus the end of the shoot
just by like how comfortable we are and
how
I mean that's just me being picky about
myself and what am I acting but I think
I've found it quite
easier to get into the role because me
and Charlie are so similar and to have
my first on-screen role as someone who I
can relate to so much and can
embody so much of myself in I think gave
me quite an easier ride
mm-hmm
yeah
well it's I I just have to say it's
amazing like it was such a great
Ensemble and everyone felt like a
cohesive group of friends I mean the
different groups right they were all
believable and everybody was acting with
like at a really high level right these
are Great Performances across the board
and actually the first time I watched
the show I didn't know it was your first
time acting and then I went back and
looked you up and I was like oh my God
that's kind of amazing
um but um yeah it's beautiful work
um another thing I wanted to ask about
thematically with the show that I
thought was really interesting is and
it's not done like in a heavy overt way
but it does feel like it runs throughout
the whole show is the sh like dealing
with mental health issues are kind of
like
you know the level of isolation anxiety
the things that these kids are going
through in a really
um I don't know honest but not
heavy-handed way and I'm curious if that
was something that you talked about with
Alice or the director
um as you were prepping the chute yeah I
I mean especially Charlie's character he
stuffers with his mental health and he
has issues that happen to in his past
which still
are with him in when we meet him in the
series and I think what I love so much
about our show is that we don't hide
away from
these issues that teenagers go through
and people go through in their daily
lives but you always no matter what
happens in the show you always know it's
going to be okay
and I think that that is something that
is such a there's a lack of in our media
because
in all the TV dramas and film dramas
today you want to create suspense and
drama and you do that by
making these scenarios in which the
characters are suffering
but what Heart Stopper does is it
creates those scenarios and creates the
drama but you you know it's going to be
okay you know Charlie's going to be okay
in the end of it and you know Nick and
Charlie are are always going to be
together so
if it makes for an both an easier watch
but also
um quite important watch for like
teenagers who might be going through
similar things and
yeah I just I love that part of it
yeah I think it's a really a really
positive portrayal of life in general
um and mental health is something that a
lot of people uh teens
T and also I think the thing is with
teens
um
are often
sort of undermined uh and
treated very much as as children uh and
they're sort of mental health can be
you know often
kind of understated by people and and
you know it's just hormones or it's just
this it's just that and really it can be
an extraordinarily difficult part of a
person's life is their teenage years
because you have so many you know
different new emotions happening and and
I think Charlie is a prime example I
think Nick you see you see things sort
of
actual like sort of pretty much
not traumatic events but you see
things happening in his life that that
really do sort of mess with his mental
health and
um mess with the way that he sees
himself and his life and uh I think that
that's
something that artza does handle
beautifully because it's you know
very very subtly written by Alice
um and but still very positively and
very
as Joe said you know that everything's
going to be okay at the end of the day
and that's um I think it's important for
people especially people who are going
through tough times to see a show where
people who are like them
or even not like them uh but just people
who are sort of going through tough
times as well but there's a sense of
hope
yeah absolutely I I
I think that probably had something to
do with why the show was so powerful for
so many people and it still is right I
mean it came out at a time when a lot of
people in very different circumstances
were dealing with hard times from the
pandemic from everything else and this
was like
I don't know it it was a real
positive experience to spend time with
with your characters
um kit I also wanted to talk about your
relationship with Olivia Coleman playing
your mom I love those scenes of the two
of you together and if you could talk
about that I mean it's some of those
moving moments are just these like the
way she responds to you when you open up
to her and things it's just so
profoundly moving and great to see on
screen
thank you it's uh you know it's it will
forever be an honor to be able to act
with someone of Olivia's sort of caliber
but also just to be out uh be acting
with someone who is
as wonderful as she is she is such a
gorgeous human being and uh a gorgeous
actor as well
um yeah she is extraordinary to work
with she's so effortless it doesn't feel
like she's trying
um it just feels like she sort of will
read a scene and you know
she might take a better Direction she
won't take this that but she understands
exactly what's going on exactly how that
character is feeling and can just
portray it so effortlessly and so subtly
um and it's so impressive to be in the
room and see her do it because you know
she can literally just bring
and it's cliche but you know bring the
words to life uh we only had about two
days to shoot with her on season one uh
and it was
it was packed you know there aren't that
many scenes really with uh with Olivia
season one but but we really did pack
everything into those two days and we
did it tactically we did
all the sort of light-hearted stuff on
the first day and then got into the
heavier stuff so I had about a day to
sort of form this this you know this
this relationship with her and have some
chemistry uh of you know sort of
of son and mother but
yeah she didn't it
I was terrified I thought it was going
to be extraordinarily difficult and it
was in many ways to sort of keep up with
her
but at the same time I find
acting with someone of her caliber you
do just
you do just find yourself trying to
trying to get out there and keep up and
I think it was really
um
yeah it was a really wonderful two days
of shooting and I was so happy with with
the final result of of that that final
scene especially it was the scene that I
really wanted to get right and I was
really hoping that we would be able to
get it right and yeah the reaction's
been beautiful really touching and
exactly what we wanted and
yeah I think that it was really a lovely
ending to the to a to a lovely show
yeah absolutely
um well
I'm not sure how to frame my last my
next question but it really has to do
with
I'm curious how and if you don't want to
answer this this is fine but my question
is really about sort of the reception of
the show and I mean you're both like I
mean can you have more experience and
you've been acting since you were much
younger but still you're like you're
young performers and this show just blew
up and impacted so many people and I'm
curious sort of I don't know just how
that experience was for you both seeing
how people responded to it and the the
kind of positive reception I got I'm
sure was lovely for both of you but just
like I don't know anything you want to
share about your experience of suddenly
being in the Limelight in that way and
having to deal with that and sort of
whatever you know the positives and
negatives of that coming off this show
I didn't know how to describe it it's
very strange
um amazing overwhelming
like
I'm so proud of our show and what we've
created as a huge group of people
um and it's so great that it's managed
to reach far more people than we ever
ever expected it to
um there's been a weird couple of months
and
yeah
that's great
yeah I think it's um it's deeply
overwhelming in many ways and and
positive ways and negative ways you know
you see
uh I've seen some absolutely
you know
just incredible reactions to the show
and meeting people and hearing the way
that they've been impacted by it and by
certain scenes and by that Pharmacy with
Olivia
um and you know some gorgeous scenes
that Joe did you know there's a gorgeous
scene with Joe and um and and Jenny who
plays
Victorious sister where they discusses
mental health and it's you know
beautifully acted and it's beautifully
written and it's you know it's it's I
cried when I when I first saw it
um
and
yeah but at the same time you do we are
both still
you know I think in some ways we're
we're mature for our age but in some
ways we're still just kids and it's
terrifying being in the big bad world uh
with a lot of eyes on you and you feel
like everything you do uh is a mistake
and that's that's it's you know it's
heavy for a for an 18 and 19 year old
um
but I would say that
you can never it's it's always been my
dream to be an actor uh and I think that
some things come with that that are you
know not 100 ideal but but
you know you have to ask yourself is it
worth
that dream and I've always wanted to to
be able to do this and and I you know
it's still my favorite thing to do is to
be able to to bring things to life on
screen and on on stage and I think that
I feel extraordinarily lucky to be able
to do that so yeah
that's that's great well so I know
you're you probably can't talk about
this but I'll I'll ask anyway
um I know you're you're in production on
season two is there anything you can
share about it does it cover the sort of
volume two of the the next phase of the
graphic novel or
whatever you can share um and and when
is it and do you know when it's coming
out
I don't know what we can say what do you
want to share Joe yeah what do you want
to share
oh no I always get told off um
it's based on Comics so yeah if you can
get an education that's from them great
yeah
um it's it's very excited and you know
people should be excited for it
and we we've had a lot of fun making it
we've we've put our you know we're
absolutely exhausted with our sort of
our Blood Sweat and Tears into it and
yeah uh we're all desperately hoping
that people like it as much as season
one great
well I you know I have to say I I didn't
I wasn't familiar with the comic before
the show and so I went back and have
read most of it and it's I mean I didn't
know Alice oseman's worked before this
and she's amazing so very excited to see
whatever the the new season is going to
be and um really thank you both so much
for doing this for talking with film
independent and um congrats on a
fantastic show and um wishing you both
great holidays and a nice break after
you wrap
thank you so much it's been a pleasure
it has the same to you
thank you so much bye-bye thank you
[Music]